foreign
that Tick Tock pushed potentially
harmful content to these users on an
average of every 39 seconds
harmful information listen to me when
you're playing with mental health you're
playing with life and death get these
devices out of your children's hands
[Music]
this is John with the Dr John deloney
show
so grateful that you are with us
live we're not really live but it sounds
cool to say that like live but we're not
um man I am just coming off a week of
being on the road and being out and
seeing some of you good folks South
Carolina to Colorado to where'd we go
Ardmore Oklahoma right outside Oklahoma
City is close to the home of Toby Keith
the famous Toby Keith Hey listen uh so
my wife was obsessed with
um
country music she still has big country
music fan I was not Kelly I'm talking to
Kelly here and I was a heavy metal kid
and a punk rock kid and um so in college
I was dating this girl who's not my wife
and she loved country music and I heard
on the radio that there was going to be
free tickets to a country music show I
waited in line for hours I didn't know
any of these people that they all were
just their names
and I got Toby Keith two tickets and I
was like hey I got I got his tickets to
a country music show and she's like
really and I told her and she's like
yeah I'm not going to that she's like
that's not for me
I know that's brutal kind of broke my
heart yeah that's brutal even now uh
it's probably what 25 26 years later
when I like try to do something nice and
she's like I'm not having it I'm like
man this feels a lot like Toby Keith
turns out he's a great guy I heard he's
a great wonderful guy he used to be over
there at Belmont where I was he would do
rehearsals and stuff and he's just a
lovely human being way to go
um I used to work in the music industry
yes and um I had a couple dealings with
him and he was he was fabulous it was
just a wonderful guy he plays a
character on on stage but he's just a
great wonderful guy I know a number of
people that have worked in his um for
his team and they have and trust me if
they don't if they have bad things to
say you know about it and nothing always
what did people say about working on
this team let's just move on let's leave
that for another show for another show
hey this is the the most important and
incredible and I'll even say uh
extraordinary mental health and marriage
and parenting podcast of all time ever
and so I'm so grateful that you've
joined us if you want to be on the show
give us a buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 and please go to
subscribe hit the like button if you're
on Apple or Spotify make sure you
subscribe
um give leave stuff five star reviews it
just helps everything so much so I'm so
grateful for your support and Care let's
go out to Ben in Lexington Kentucky in
the KY what's up Ben
hi I'm not much Dr John how you doing
and we're rocking and rolling man y'all
doing well awesome all right well it's a
little cold here it's cold it is cold so
what's up dude how can I help man
uh well um me and my wife we've been
together for 13 years okay I've been
married for almost a year and she's
always had this idea that I've been
cheating on her and it's getting to the
point where I just I just can't handle
it anymore because
uh you know I'm not cheating on her and
no matter what I tell her
it's always she's got an answer for it
so my question is what can I possibly do
to
keep her from thinking I'm cheating on
her
that's tough man
it's like you're trying to love somebody
and she keeps like putting a wedge
between you right
yeah or coming up with reasons why you
can't get close so
you kind of have a unique relationship
you are together 12 years and then
you've been married for one what what
took so long almost four years
we got married and you know her as well
um took a decade
yeah yeah I know it's crazy but hey man
teach their own teach their own but here
you are right that's right how long has
she accused you of cheating on her for
the entirety of our relationship I mean
it's I mean it comes and goes it's it's
not an everyday thing but whenever it is
a thing she just never lets it go so
what are the things she points out that
would suggest you're cheating
she says I'm
sorry are you and
I have no social media
um and if I am on my phone it's it's
either taking phone calls or or just
looking at just like tractor equipment
you know it's just something you know
something nothing you know and I don't
think she realizes a person who's on
their phone all the time because it's
not me gotcha
um
so I don't have any like empirical data
to back this up I'm just going to tell
you something I've seen over and over
and over and over and over again for the
last 20 plus years okay yeah
the things that we are often capable of
or that we've often been guilty of or
that we often think about doing are the
things we often project onto other
people
okay and so my question to you would be
out of the gate has she ever cheated on
you
not that I'm aware of would it stun you
or would it melt you
oh absolutely yeah okay so it wouldn't
be something if you were like yeah I
could see that it would be out of the
blue
yeah has somebody ever cheated on her in
a previous relationship that was that
was like a nuclear bomb inside of her
well you know
we'll be over here for so long I mean I
I heard her relationships before me were
pretty
she hasn't spoke on it so I I can't
really
I don't know
um but you know if I had to point to
something that's that her parents are
divorced
um I don't know
if there was infidelity in their
relationship because that
um there's always conflicting stories
between them sure but uh you know that's
not the only thing I could possibly
think of well and it may be that she
picked up that relationships look like
one person accusing the other person all
of the time yeah and that may have been
which the the norm that she grew up with
and in a weird way in a way of trying to
circumvent and prevent or as brene Brown
says dress for her tragedy like she
spends a lot of time thinking about what
happens what happens what happens what
happens and then she has to ask you and
then it kind of bubbles up and she
explodes on you and you're like what are
you talking about and then it kind of it
it simmers a little bit and it starts
building back up again and up again
you end up creating the very thing that
your body's trying to protect you from
and that's how you get family
dysfunction that happens year after year
generation after generation is in a way
of trying to prevent you from cheating
and driving her crazy what's gonna
happen is are you leaving is somebody
you're gonna run into is gonna be super
chill
and they're gonna laugh at your jokes a
little bit they're going to reach over
and grab something from you and kind of
brush your arm and you're gonna like it
and it's that's how these things in
Seoul is gonna just slowly tilt the
other way right has that happened to you
I mean
there's been moments where just women
have spoke to me and how dare you been
just kidding I know it's crazy
I understand all right so let's do this
um
there is not a single thing you can do
the the if I was going to put some blame
somewhere I would start with you and
blame's kind of dramatic I hate using
that word but
um you knew this going in
right if you called and were like dude
out of nowhere she's just insane about
me cheating that would be one thing you
knew this and so part of me says I mean
you you made the bed and you're just
lining it now you're upset that it's
uncomfortable so there is that okay uh
and if any con if you're gonna have a
conversation with her a direct
conversation I would start there I have
to own my my part in this this has been
going on for a long long time
um and maybe now that you are living
together 24 7 365 it's Amplified or
whatever
um let me ask you that question why now
why are you just done now
I probably should have mentioned this
before too she is pregnant and I don't
know if it's her hormones getting all
crazy or what have you but she just
recently whenever I uh emailed you my
question she blew up on me just because
I showed up at the house
without my phone
I mean I just completely forgot it at
the farm
um you know I just it was a total
accident and she just blew up and I'm
like she wouldn't listen to anything I
said and it just it just really
frustrated me yeah and you know because
I wasn't feeling good that day and she
knew that and I was just stopping by
just to get some aspirin and and instead
of you know asking how I was and you
know are you okay she just automatically
said you know I think you're cheating on
me why don't you have your phone on you
um and all this so it you know I it was
just a bad situation so what's your
what's your or what moment
ah
really know John did you leave her in
this new baby no absolutely not okay
so you're caught between
a value I'm not going anywhere
and I can't keep living like this
right
and I think she knows that
okay
so here's a couple of ways a couple
things I would I would tell you first is
um I'm sure you've done this but I it's
it's worth doing it again
probably writing her a letter and I want
you to and here's why writing a letter
is important because I want you to read
her this letter and then I want you to
give it to her
and there's some research about
um the importance of writing things down
that you might stumble over verbally but
when you write it down and you have time
to you know hit the backspace and you
spend the time getting it out it's a lot
more articulate and you get everything
out you get more out than when you try
to talk your body gets nervous you kind
of sees up a little bit and there's been
some studies with social media that
suggests like when I was a kid you know
if the school bully on the bus like
talked trash to me and said something
really rude it hurt but there's some
natural mechanisms inside our bodies
that help us that that it kind of
dissipates out over time especially if
that person is not like my parents or
somebody in my closed Circle when it
comes to social media it's black and
white and it's posted and so you can
read it over and over and over and over
again that same thing I'm going with the
idea that it also works in reverse and
I've seen this over and over where if
you tell her I'm not cheating on you she
is already accused you she's in fight or
flight game is on she's not hearing any
new data she's just in a fight now but
when she's calm and she goes back to
this letter and then she's calm later on
goes back to this letter and she's at
peace and goes back to this letter
it's going to reinforce and reinforce
and reinforce okay so I'd recommend
writing this stuff down and then taking
her out somewhere and reading it to her
okay
um it will probably be hard to read but
it's important that you have a clear
path ahead for her
I would note that this is
um on you not on her okay the moment you
sit and then you do that then she's off
right she's got to defend herself
the statements that I would make are
I work really really hard to love you
the best I can
and I'm beginning to feel
um like I can't breathe because every
moment I walk in this house I'm being
accused of being a liar and a cheater
two things that I don't put up with in
my life I don't put up with my friends
and I'm struggling to continue to um be
connected in this relationship because
it's a constant attack
and
I think the next statement I would go
with and again this is just me
I'm choosing to be well I want to be a
good dad I want to be a good husband and
I can't continue to do it in this
context so when you choose to accuse me
of something that I have not done will
never do
I'm gonna choose you're choosing to send
me away and I'm going to choose to go
for a walk to take a little kid out to
head back to the farm I'm going to
choose to not be in this situation I'm
not going to leave you but I'm gonna
choose to be well as well as I possibly
can how does that sound
it sounds good but you know I just I
just know her and I don't know I just
don't know if she'll I feel like I've
done all those things just not in a
letter form and it's it's like it goes
in one ear and out the other honestly I
I don't know how she would handle that I
I know and I I would tell you it's time
to take a stand
and I tried and and you know here's the
problem with taking the stand is you're
not going to leave you're not going
anywhere
yeah and but
I guess it's you know that's that's the
thing is she knows that I'm not going to
leave and it's almost like I have to
leave and then just see what what how
she changes
right or if she does or if you leaving
validates all of her fears that she's
been coming have you have you talked to
her about going to marriage counseling
no I I know I'll be honest I don't know
if I want to go to marriage counseling
you know I just well that's done why
wouldn't you want to go
well I just I like to work things out
myself you know I know I'm calling you
it's not working yeah it's 13 years it's
not working
I know I know I like to fix my car by
myself too and that usually doesn't work
and I have to take it into someone
yeah is that fair
yeah that's yeah I mean you're right
here's the deal
um I've said this before and get a
little bit of smoke from it and I don't
care I look at Fidelity in a marriage
relationship in a romantic relationship
much bigger
than
somebody putting a body part inside of
somebody else
so like I know it's easy to say like
Fidelity I've never cheated on anybody
I've never had sex with somebody else
I think Fidelity and cheating and being
whole in a marriage is way bigger than
sex
I think that somebody who walks in and
steals your dignity every day calls you
a liar to your face repeatedly over and
over and over again
someone who you've probably shown all of
your phone or all of your text and all
of your deleted stuff and you've
probably they've probably tracked you
around with the little app and all that
stuff oh yeah so what you're what you
have to realize you're not dealing with
data here you're not dealing with
there's not a thing you can do there's
not like a data point that she's gonna
go ah okay phew that's not gonna happen
and I think there's a bigger issue here
when it comes to cheating or it comes to
Fidelity in a relationship she is making
choices to separate the two of you
or she's making choices to not be in
relationship with you
and she's choosing to do that not by
having sex with somebody else that you
know of but she's choosing to put wedges
between the two of you so that you
cannot get close
and then she's blaming you for that
distance
see what I'm saying yeah I get it yeah
this is a bigger deal than I think you
are allowing yourself to believe it to
be
well I know it's a big deal
um but I just I don't know I just I just
wish it would stop I think that dude you
know that's the greatest line of this
Show's history I know it's a big deal I
just wish it would stop that's exactly
right that's exactly exactly exactly
right 100 percent
you're you're a a good man who works on
the farm and when a problem like
presents itself yeah you fix that
problem and you literally take baling
wire and uh some hay and you solve that
problem and maybe some duct tape and you
can't do that on this one
because somebody on the other field just
keeps throwing cocktail Molotov
cocktails on your field and setting it
on fire and at some point you can't just
keep going out there and putting out the
fire you have to stop and say enough is
enough is enough
and quite frankly I think the step
forward is marriage counseling because
something is going on inside of your
wife
that is making her that is that is
pushing her that is encouraging her to
choose to
make the guy that loves her more than
anybody on planet Earth the bad guy
constant bad guy an inability to be at
peace in relationship she is choosing an
anxious life
and there's not a thing you can do about
it at this point other than to begin to
create a world where you have to protect
yourself and the world that this little
baby is going to come into
I would be on the first train into a
marriage counselor because this this
relationship has a little has very short
legs on it if you don't get involved
very very quickly and get a third party
in there
you've tried your best my man you've
tried and you just want to go away
you've tried to solve it and it's not
so now you can do one of two things
accept what is
and live a life of quiet desperation
hang your head low like millions and
millions and millions of men have done
or you can look at her and say you're
worth fighting for we are worth fighting
for this family's worth fighting for and
I'm not giving up I'm calling a marriage
counselor and we gotta go do this
because we need help right now thanks
for the call then we'll be right back
[Music]
all right people all of us procrastinate
about something maybe you've been
ignoring your check engine light or
maybe you've been putting off plans to
read more whatever it is good sleep is
not something to put off sleep is the
foundation for your mental and physical
health and like your check engine light
your old mattress won't just fix itself
so don't procrastinate here quality
sleep starts with a great mattress like
dream cloud with their one year in-home
trial there's no excuse to keep tossing
and turning on your old mattress that
keeps getting more uncomfortable by the
night
it's time to invest in good sleep and
dream cloud is the only luxury brand
that gives you a full year to try out
your new mattress a full year stop
procrastinating I know you'll love your
dream Cloud right away just like my
family does right now dream cloud is
offering my listeners 25 off your order
plus 50 in additional savings and why
not
599 dollars in accessories with promo
code John deloney that's pillows luxury
sheets and a mattress protector so go on
dreamcloudsleep.com and use promo code
John deloney today and also probably
don't ignore that check engine light for
very much longer
all right we are back for everybody's
favorite segment with nobody's favorite
music facts are your friends let's do it
Joe
oh gosh
still no Kelly like literally one job as
a producer is to have not terrible music
oh trust me there are so many other jobs
and I've told you before we're going to
just chill all right I don't do good at
chili oh I'm fully aware of that I don't
either so I get that one of my spiritual
gifts and that's kind I think when a
woman tells a man hey just chill it's
kind of like when a guy tells a girl
just calm down just calm down and no one
in the history of the world has ever
calmed down by being told that not one
time
all right let's go to this article that
you handed me Kelly
I'm so thrilled about this actually
right when I saw the title hemorrhoids I
went to got some Preparation H which
should sponsor the show because I give
them so much free air time and here it
is I was at a CBS News so we know it's
factually correct
teens turning to tick tock for mental
health advice are self-diagnosing
oh man
um a third year psychology student says
this if I'm trying to figure out how to
do something I feel like it's easier to
go on tick tock
so just I want everyone to catch how
quickly the world has shifted
I went to college
um in the late 90s and in in the 2000s I
went to college and I paid a professor I
paid the university who then paid the
professor for the knowledge that was in
their head now granted I could have gone
to the public library like Google
hunting says I could have done that but
there was information in my professor's
heads that I did not have access to and
I was paying for that access and in fact
there's some old colleges I think Oxford
there's several colleges that you can't
go into the building you can't go into
the psychology building unless you're a
major you couldn't go into the
architecture building unless you were a
major they protected the information
because that's what these students were
paying for and this was a special
incubated world and then the internet's
hit and then very quickly it was about
two thousand I don't know several years
ago
I ordered my wife backed up and knocked
the side mirror off the car and so in an
old Prius and so I got on on eBay and
bought one had it shipped to the house
my dad came my dad's um good at fixing
stuff and so we went out to fix it
together
as we're walking outside in the dark he
says into his phone
repairing 2010 passenger side mirror
Prius
um video and I was like oh gosh my old
man's losing it and then YouTube pops up
the video the exact step-by-step thing I
was like oh man
I don't really need what's in a
mechanic's head anymore I can get this
there may be some tools I don't have
there may be some like time I don't have
the time to fix this thing or there may
be some expertise I don't have a lift or
whatever
but the days win like I would go to a
mechanic and say I don't know what's
wrong I don't know how to fix this thing
that's over because I can get that
information on YouTube now
and in just a few short years it's gone
from YouTube which is millions and
millions and millions and millions of
people doing things and uploading their
process they just put up cameras and say
I'm going to give this information to
the world for free some of it's trash
and garbage much of it's great a lot of
it's just great stuff
um I built a uh compost box over the
weekend I got the plans off YouTube I
just punched it in I'd have to pay for
it I mean it's just a wild New World
we're in and I don't think we fully
grasp it and then you go one step
further to tick tock which takes
an eight minute video or a 25 minute
video or maybe even a three minute video
and turns it into a 30 second 15 second
clip
now here's where this is dicey I put
stuff on on Tick Tock so I've got a I'm
a part of this system let me tell you
why
um for those of you who are not
um people of Faith there's an old story
in the Old Testament
um
by a guy named Jonah right and anybody
knows Jonah a body got eaten by a fish
and yada that's not the important part
of the story at all the important part
of the story is
there was a group of people that The
Story Goes God wanted to save
and he said those are terrible people I
don't want anything to do with this
system I don't want to be a part of this
thing they're not worth saving and he
was told that's exactly where I want you
and so that story is always resonated
with me is when people are hurting when
people are struggling people I don't
like that's where I need to go
when there is a system that I don't that
is just full of garbage I need to head
into that not run away from it not thumb
my nose so
I have such disdain for 17 year olds
getting on social media platforms and in
30 seconds Googling what some diagnostic
is and being reductive and saying I feel
this and this and so I have this and you
have this too here's what you need to do
have warm lemon water and some essential
oils and your depression will just go
that is so dangerous
I've entered into that world to try to
bring some sort of Sanity to it and I
know people with wisdom and experience
and the right credentials have done that
so I want to call that out I've headed
into Tick Tock so it's weird for me to
be talking about how dangerous I think
all this stuff is and what nonsense this
is but the idea is the article says
social media therapy
she was diagnosed this woman was
diagnosed with anxiety and depression by
the time she was in fifth grade she was
had begun having suicidal thoughts even
with therapy her struggles with anxiety
and thoughts about self-harm made her
feel alone there was no one I thought
could help me and I started looking for
other people through social media that I
looked through Instagram any social
media could then tick tock
on Tick Tock the hashtag mental health
has been searched more than 67 billion
times
67 billion times now getting traction is
referred to as social media therapy
they're going into these spaces to the
soothe themselves to make themselves
feel better to make themselves the
master of that environment when they
don't feel that they've mastered the
environment of the outside world let me
repeat that in English when you go
scroll and you feel like you feel a
little bit better you get some super
quote or something like yeah
and you don't take that quote to the
real world you just sit there and baste
in it you'll feel better but you're
feeling better in a fake fantasy world
it's not real
because as soon as you move into the
real world and the your parents
relationship or your mom being upset
with you or your in-laws deciding what
you do Christmas or your spouse is
looking at pornography instead of
talking to you like those things are
real and what happens is we go to these
devices to get these little quips and
get these little Clips to make ourselves
feel better oh I've got this diagnosis
I've got this issue this 22 year old
influencer told me I have a thing and
it's this and this is why and I'm just
going to stay here and then the
algorithms learns what you like and it
just keeps pumping it in and pumping it
in and now you are sitting in a trash
can
swimming in sewage
while the world spins outside
the real world just keeps spinning
outside of of this little
digital box
it says this
um as you look through Tick Tock the
algorithm strengthens it turned into
diagnosis turned into other things like
ADHD borderline personality disorder and
more depression anxiety
I'll read this last one in one recent
study by the center for counseling
countering digital hate researchers
posed as 13 year olds and searched and
liked mental health videos they found
that Tick Tock pushed potentially
harmful content to these users on an
average of every 39 seconds
harmful information wrong crap
and listen to me when you're playing
with mental health you're playing with
life and death
you're playing with long-term damage to
people
some users received recommendations for
Content about suicide within 2.6 minutes
of joining the app
what's online is a free-for-all and
there's really no accountability for
this and there's no responsibility taken
here's the last one
Canadian Journal of Psychiatry of
popular Tick Tock videos about ADHD 52
percent were deemed misleading one out
of two
so what do we do with all this
I want to Circle back to you moms and
dads get these devices out of your
children's hands stop
I cannot get mad at a 13 year old or a
15 year old or a 12 year old or a
nine-year-old for not wanting to talk to
their parents about something fine
they're kids I'll give them that
but I put the blame squarely on Mom and
Dad for handing them these devices and
saying here Run free and if you have any
crazy Converse like oh what's oral sex
you know instead of asking somebody who
might know I'm just gonna google it I'll
just look on Tick Tock hey what's
depression I feel bad
um mom was mean to me today because I
got a D in class because I didn't study
um
I'm gonna get on Tick Tock oh I've got
depression I've got major depressive
disorder and my mom's got narcissism
narcissistic personality disorder this
is what and now we're off to the races
and then you tell a friend at school and
that friend says hey I've got something
for you and they hand you Xanax or the
hand you Adderall they hand you
something else and the percentage of
that crap that has fentanyl in it is
it's it's just a whole domino take the
phones back take your kids lives back
stop sending them to tick tock
stop allowing them and if all the
propaganda bullcrap is true about other
countries running Tick Tock and trying
to dude what are we doing
this whole thing there are people out
there trying to debunk misinformation
and good for them I'm trying I'm trying
you notice I don't talk a lot about
Diagnostics I talk more about how to
treat people how to take care of people
but at the end of the day
I think this is a really simple solvable
problem and that means our kids are
going to be mad at us for a season
they're not gonna like us that's fine
that's our job as parents is not to be
liked all the time our job is to protect
their kids and we have to take this crap
out of our kids hearts and Minds
we have to be adults that are likable
that give them an opportunity to come
back and talk to us they are desperate
for adults to say hey I love you I like
you
I'm likable
what's going on in your world
they're desperate for it moms and dads
start showing up enough with the digital
babysitters
enough
let's take back our kids
let's take back our kids we'll be right
back
hey good folks John deloney here I feel
like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show what you'd like to see more of what
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
askjohn ramseysolutions.com with your
feedback thank you for being such an
important part of the show rock on
all right we're back let's go to will in
Athens not Greece Georgia what's up will
what's going on you never heard that
joke before have you I'm incredible
definitely have never heard that one
before uh my friends call me Chappelle
Junior nobody calls me that actually
what's up dude
hey so I've got a question
um and I'm just gonna straight shoot it
so how turn off and
arms after a season of trauma and then
kind of the second part to that is how
do I better manage trauma next time
around if it's cool I'd like to give you
give you some context of that and just
not have a question yeah for sure
so my wife so I'm 25 I'm and my wife's
26 we were married in June of 2021
um and so we got married and it was it
was awesome and then we uh went on our
honeymoon had a great time we came back
to kind of start our life
um and then two months after we got back
uh I got a call from My Wife and she was
in tears and she had to leave work
because she was having some some
incredible back pain
um and so after some doctor's visits
um we found out that she had actually
hurt her spine when she was younger but
it wasn't that bad but she works at a
vet's office and so she was lifting some
animals and when she did that it ended
up fracturing her spine
um and so for that entire fall we were
doing doctor's visits and and trying to
get with her insurance to try to solve
the problem but slowly her spine was
slipping more and more and so it was
causing her more and more pain and so by
the time got to January she was starting
to lose feeling in her legs she couldn't
walk anymore and it just it got
progressively worse luckily we got
surgery in that February of last year
and after the surgery uh it they were
able to secure her spine she had a great
prognosis but the doctors were saying
that it was going to be about eight
months for her to recover back to normal
um and so during those eight months you
know I had to kind of help her do things
like going to the bathroom and taking a
shower and cooking her food and just
just kind of being a caretaker and
taking care of her while she couldn't
work so we didn't have her income
anymore I'm a full-time student and I
work full-time I had both of those going
on
um and just kind of I just took care of
her and and just tried to meet her needs
during that time and then
um you know we actually so now where
she's recovered a lot and she's able to
get back to kind of a normal life she's
been able to go back to work
um and she like we're kind of coming out
of this season of trauma but I was
sitting in class in January and I just
had this feeling of like oh my God I'm
gonna die like I like I'm freaking out
and my heart started racing
um and it was just full-on panic attack
and so I was in this lecture hall and I
just kind of ran out of the lecture hall
kind of like a crazy person and I was
just kind of in the hallway right when
you were saying that I was thinking
welcome to the club man welcome to the
game you're not crazy at all man not
crazy at all yeah and so you know I
after that I just had like insane just
health anxiety just constantly in my
head of like I have this cancer and this
cancer and just kind of like what you
were talking about in the last segment I
was just like spun out on looking up
diagnosis and my wife was like you've
got to stop that it's driving you crazy
I love it and I was like you're totally
right I love I love the one recruiting
from spine surgery is telling the
healthy one dude you're gonna have to
just dial it back 30 she's like you're
fine yeah but all that to say basically
is that you know we had we had this
trauma and now we're kind of coming out
of it and it seems like we're at the
tail end of it but now my body like the
whole time I was kind of like I'm
pushing through I'm serving my wife this
is great and now my body decides to spin
out when we're when it seems like we're
recovering is that that's right
absolutely so here's where I want you to
start well let me say this you are one
thousand percent right where you should
be
okay
right where you should be there's
nothing wrong with you you're an amazing
husband she won the lottery with you and
probably you could you would say the
same thing
um you stepped up in a tremendous time
of need what a gift and you've laid some
foundational some foundations to the
homes that you and your wife are going
to build moving forward
um that will be Legacy shifting your
kids and your grandkids are going to be
different because of what you did in the
season okay I don't want you to lose
that it's huge
the place you need to start both of you
but particularly no both of you I was
gonna say particularly you but both of
you are in the season
is grief
here's why
all grief is is the gap between what I
hoped would happen what I thought this
was going to look like in reality
endude for a long time you couldn't wait
to marry this girl right
right and y'all are gonna rock it till
the wheels came off y'all are gonna be a
dual income family you're gonna make
this much money you're gonna live in
this place you're going to travel to
these places you can do all these stuff
you're gonna go to school and you can do
this and everything fell apart
and so there's a part of your body that
is continuing that narrative and trying
to catch up to that narrative trying to
make that narrative happen
and there's the other part of you that
is dealing with the day-to-day reality I
have to help my wife go to the bathroom
because she can't move
and what a panic attack is an anxiety
attack there's some there are some
physiological differences for this
conversation that it's not really worth
digging into but
it's your body saying hey dude I'm out
if you're not gonna stop I'm stopping us
and there just came a point when school
and as you were talking here's what I
wrote down middle of a pandemic you got
married that sounds cool that means you
dated through a pandemic planned a
wedding through a pandemic awesome
um
a complete and total lack of control and
autonomy you watch somebody you love be
in so much pain they couldn't move right
right that's disorienting that's scary
and for a lot of us we've never had that
kind of scary before until we see it for
the first time when we're older and it's
disorienting
tell me if this is true after a year of
intense caretaking trying to be a good
new husband also going to school when's
the last time you started just hung out
regularly with a group of guys
yeah
uh it's it happens it's just not as
regularly as it used to be that's right
it's really easy to to be look up and
and suddenly at six months it's eight
months and you're really lonely or you
just get together and you all hang out
and you're not dude I'm not gonna get
into all of what's been going on and you
and they're like man sorry you're like
it's cool bro and then you're off to
watching the game or eating chips and
whatever and you're down that road like
you're past the hey I'm not okay guys
and so you find yourself lonely
Financial insecurity you'll have some
plans right and all of a sudden this
many Doctor Bills is a lot right
you see it I mean it's just piling up
piling up
here's what I think would be really
helpful for y'all and here here's all we
want you to do
we want you to do a couple of things to
show your brain
that you're not running on fight or
flight anymore that you are in the
driver's seat
that I'm in control now I'm back I'm
here
and you can be in the driver's seat in
the crappiest situations and not be
anxious that's the whole idea behind a
non-anxious life but I want you to spend
some time and it'd probably be good for
her to do it too
to just write down we thought the first
year and a half of our marriage is going
to look like this and here's what it's
look like
and be real specific in real graphic I
did never thought
that I would have to wipe my wife I did
I did a lot I never thought I thought
showering would be
different than what it ended up being
there's a there's a romantic shower and
then there's a therapeutic show those
are very different experience right see
what I'm saying like I want you to be
very specific about this and if y'all
are gangsters read these letters to you
because here's the other thing she's got
a whole bunch of guilt and a whole bunch
of shame that is she should not be
carrying either right
sure and she told you she thought she
ruined the first year
can't believe you have to do all this
stuff
right yep is that true too
yep yeah dude you see like and so listen
your body's just trying to get your
attention that things aren't okay
this is less about responding to crises
and more about hey we're not safe
financially we're not safe relationally
you're lonely you have no control of
what happens tomorrow sounding every
alarm I got
and then you are such a hard driver
you're like well I'm going to grad
school so I gotta go to class after my
full-time job after bathing my wife and
then your body's like dude we're out
it may be a season to take a semester
off
to go in there and ask for incompletes
and finish up next semester it may just
be time to give her I did that multiple
times through both all three of my
graduate degrees
just took a semester off I it's too much
going on here at home or it may be a
time when you say I gotta hire some help
and get some help or maybe you see what
I'm saying but it's it's settling into
okay here's what we wanted this to be
and here's our reality that is not gonna
happen the thing that we wanted we got
to grieve it we gotta let it go and now
we got to build what comes next and it
may be that man I'd hope to have a
graduate degree but how old are you 25
25. okay what are you going to grad
school for
interior software engineering
computer saw wow you're really smart huh
I'm The Logical she is like the fun
creative like let's do everything and
just be weird and crazy and I'm gonna
let's stay in a line and do things by
the book and build blocks awesome so
that will kill you in this season
acknowledging grief for you is loosening
your grip on the Wheel
because you've clamped down on that
sucker haven't you
absolutely yeah
and dude you're too good of a guy the
world needs you
for you to die of a stroke or a heart
attack at 35 years old
right and a lot of that comes from
sitting in grief
I thought I could control everything and
come to find out I can't and that sucks
and then looking over and saying but I
do love you and I do love what we're
building together and we're going to
build something completely new
I want you to write a letter I want her
to write a letter and I want you all to
read them to each other
and then here's the second part of the
exercise I want you all to um
I want you to write okay here's what
happens next in the next six months
that's it the next six months here's
what happens next
and hold it very very Loosely and check
in once a week check in once a month for
a little bit deeper dive
how's the six months we had a plan how's
it going how's it working and she might
tell you how about we take the plan and
wad it up and use it as two ply and you
could be like that sounds great but
we're gonna just say okay here's our new
reality and then in six months we're
gonna plan a new one then we're gonna
plan a new one then we're gonna plan a
new it's gonna be an ongoing planning
season the idea that you're going to put
us all in a spreadsheet at 25 and it's
going to roll out when you're 75. that
time is over it's not gonna work and I'm
glad you got to learn it now most of us
learn that in our 30s and 40s and then
we think like we shouldn't be married
because it gets caustic you learned it
young good for you man
but I want to give your wife an
opportunity to speak her guilt and shame
that's unwarranted and you look around
the eye and say no no it's been my
life's greatest gift to be able to walk
alongside you and I want her to be able
to look at you and say I know you had a
bunch of plans and they're sideways
let's make new ones let's do that
together we'll hang on the line we're
gonna I'm gonna send you both
um the first and the second edition of
the couples questions for humans y'all
can sit around and chit chat with each
other and maybe get weird and dude again
thank you so much for being a husband
who steps up or a husband who loves his
wife and for being brave enough to tell
your story
a lot of us need to hear that
Gentlemen let's step up we'll be right
back
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
please don't forget to hit the Subscribe
button to send this episode to somebody
who you think it would mean something
important to and to leave five star
reviews and tell us that we're wonderful
um helps get the message out and I'm
really really grateful send this to
everybody you know
um and as we wrap up today hey uh this
is super big news Kelly took Jenna out
for tattoos this weekend and she got
Jenna got in Old English across her back
the Kesha with the dollar sign and
underneath it tick tock so
congratulations Jenna you're going down
the uh Rabbit Hole here you're gonna
have to spend a lot of money on uh
makeup the biggest kadala ha fan on the
planet what is it that's what my brother
used to call her because the S is a
dollar sign a dollar huh Kesha look at
that look at that ironic Gen X humor Jin
why she is so not what's the generation
my parents yeah I'm a Gen X she's a
millennial between gen Z and Millennial
uh well that ironic Millennial humor
there I go
[Laughter]
her favorite song it's called tick tock
this ought to be good
wake up in the morning feeling like P
Diddy hey what's up girl
grab my glasses I'm out the door I'm
gonna hit the city let's go before I
leave brush my teeth with a bottle of
Jack because when I leave for the night
I ain't coming back that makes sense I'm
gonna have horrific breath I'm talking
pedicure on our toes toes trying on all
our clothes clothes boys blowing up our
phones phones drop top and play on our
favorite CDs pulling up to the parties
trying to get a little bit tipsy dude
you already brushed your teeth in Jack
Daniels your Tipsy enough good grief
whatever Tick-Tock on
if this is the problem America is the
problem gotta solve this we need to call
Vanilla Ice you said there was a problem
you'd solve it and we checked out the
hook while the DJ revolved where are you
ice we need your help we'll see you soon